metro police officer charleston
hartfield as you'll remember went to the
route 91 harvest festival as a fan back
in 2017 he was off duty he was there
with his wife when the shooting started
he jumped into action and he lost his
life in the process for the last two
years his service and his bravery has
been at the center of a charity hockey
game in hartfield's honor i was there
that his son isaiah agreed to be
interviewed for the first time
mid-september at lifeguard arena it was
packed on the ice veterans in white
first responders in blue at center ice
the real reason everyone showed up to
support the family of charleston
hartfield my father was a great man
isaiah hartfield is his son he lived to
serve everyone around him his community
his children his family officer
charleston hartfield army veteran
charleston hartfield he gave his life in
the one october shooting
on this night they play for the
hartfield cup means the world to me
honestly to see my dad's name carried on
in such a
an amazing fashion it's been four years
since isaiah lost his father at first it
was difficult to
move on four years later it's still
difficult honestly
especially when when this time of year
comes around emotions start to come back
up but for the most part we we're
getting along pretty well isaiah now
attends the university of oregon he
might try and walk onto the football
team next year but more importantly he's
turning this trauma into a lifetime
lesson it gives me a legacy to look up
to it it really kind of puts my
perspective in check you know it it um
it really broadens my horizon and it
reminds me to be a better person every
day because i'm not only living for
myself but i'm looking to kind of carry
on his name as well
well today isaiah says the hartfield
family will be with close friends to
honor their loss they'll also go to the
healing garden to pay their
respects they go there every year